hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
so in negativity and ethics with five
Aristotle's overarching topic is what is
justice and he doesn't start off by
giving you a definition and he doesn't
start off by saying here is we are going
to lay it out instead what he says is
it's an equivocal term people will
disagree about this and that's something
I think you've experienced Thanksgiving
is coming up pretty soon so you know
just for an example what are some of the
things you shouldn't talk about the
dinner table if you don't honey people
right I'm starting dad yeah they say
politics religion and then it varies
some people say you shouldn't talk about
finances of those people will talk about
sex and why the religion okay
people have different viewpoints
sometimes it has to do with justice and
fairness doesn't the politics is by its
very nature about about justice about
fairness and people have different
conceptions of what exactly is
consistent and not only may they have
different conceptions based on their
experiences
personal interest the class history
who's been screwed before who's been on
top before all that sort of stuff the
very nature of justice itself is
complicated and there's a tendency among
people to make it simpler than it is and
every time that you oversimplify
something that's complex it's going to
blow up in your face sooner or later you
know you can you'll realize this when
you get a little bit older if you try to
simplify your taxes you don't feel like
actually doing what the IRS wants you to
do you're going to like write in some
numbers that seem right to you you'll
get a lot right because things are more
complicated same thing happens in
relationships you know tell your spouse
well we just have these problems here's
a bi-partisan your party is all very
simple and then watch the situation blow
up so the same thing happens with claims
of you to the right thing the wrong
thing this is right this is wrong
we have different conceptions with us
because it's an inherently it's okay
it's an inherently complex thing so one
of the things that's running through all
of Aristotle's stuff is justice if we
want to talk about it a full set is some
sort of disposition happens this is what
would make it a virtue or if you want to
say injustice is a vice that it has to
be something that you're saying about
people not just situations not just
actions but about people if you wanna
say
is themselves unjust really see that
time you say unfair there that person in
this respect you have to be able to give
some sort of explanation in terms of how
they typically get something that's part
of your character so what is justice
make a person you know likely to do it
makes them act to be just well that's
nice but that doesn't tell you a lot
because we still don't know what it is
to be just right
Aristotle also says it makes you act
justly and also like a virtue ought to
makes you want or desire justice to
occur what you know whether it's
yourself whether it's others so this
respect it's like all the other virtues
if you're a courageous person you like
what other people are courageous it
bothers you and other people are cowards
or rash if you're a temperate person you
don't like seeing other people over
indulging a trend you go off and you
like seeing people restrain their
appetites if you have a good humor you
know you know you don't go too far you
don't like when people do go too far
engage in humor that's just vicious or
hurting other people we're a very bad
taste but when people have something to
say that's funny and within the you know
boundaries of their taste your love it's
the same way adjustments if you may
actually are a just person you not only
do the right thing you want to do the
right thing and you recognize the
consider now you could youcould life
justice without already being a just
person you're you can struggle to be a
just person the person who's fully just
doesn't have to struggle with the rest
of us probably do have to struggle quit
against our you know our instincts and
appetites and when we want to make
exceptions for ourself and that's right
the person who is unjust generally
doesn't realize that they're unjust they
their viewpoint has become skewed in the
Kendall moral blindness but again does
this told us what justice really
consistent yeah so what I want to do at
the spark can lay out six different ways
in which Aristotle talks about justice
or injustice and you might not have
caught these when you're reading this
through for the first or secondary the
third time or item catches four years
took me a while time to ferret these up
because the way aerosol presents it is
is confusing it parts he actually like
does so if he was teaching if you he was
lecturing a lot of people think these
are lecture notes he kind of screwed his
audience over by saying I'm going to
talk about two kinds of justice and then
talking about three times you know and
saying oh yeah by the way there's a
subject and I'm turning it in and it's
not it's not either one of these others
we'll get to that but first he starts
out by saying are we won't understand
what all this means maybe would be
helpful to look at the compass or
justice in justice so when you say that
somebody is unjust how do we how do we
understand that what do we and he says
there's two main employees and
so one of these is that the person
breaks the law they violate the norms
they break the rules think about
cheating for example right and in say a
test what are the rules that a person
who's cheating is breaking it might be
something like you're not allowed to
bring in notes to my crib notes what are
other ways people cheat I suppose if
you're really all sophisticated you had
like an earpiece and something like that
yeah okay that's an interesting one
because the other thing that he talks
was people being unfair and looking at
somebody else's the answers is kind of
being unfair so taking your more than
your fair share but there's usually
rules like don't look at other people's
work right or you can't bring in knows
you can't get extra devices you can't
steal the test ahead of time to look at
it so one way that you can be getting
justice is breaking the law so the
opposite of that would be it's called a
law those who follow the law are just in
that sense so pay your taxes you
register your car what are other things
you can gauge
when you're engaged in you know
transactions you pay for the pizza that
you bought you pay for the clothes
you're being a just person at least in
the trivial sense you're not breaking
any rules you sign yourself up for
something you follow through that's
being just another way of thinking about
it is in terms of fairness and we'll get
to that he takes a little digression and
you may have found this stuff really
confusing because one of the laws
supposed to do the laws are not just
supposed to be like a bunch of
guardrails that keep us from being
complete jerks to each other in ancient
philosophy and medieval philosophy as
well even in a lot of modern philosophy
laws are understood as having a role in
making us good people so he has an
example he says you know the law says
when you get angry you're not allowed to
just go hit the law can't actually make
you like forgive people but by
restraining you from hitting it's
supposed to be teaching you certain
boundaries that you should you should
respect so it can promote a minimal
level of virtue like Martin Luther King
said a lot can't make a man love me but
it can keep them from from killing
that's that's a game but beyond that
when laws are actually done well when
institutions are functioning well and
cultures blushing and societies are
working well they actually make people
virtuous they inculcate values like
temperance courage good humor
friendliness you know all these things
we looked at before so we have certain
sets justice if we're going to look at
it like a really big picture with the
what Aristotle calls deep virtue the and
he qualifies this by saying
and virtue towards others or social to
be a just person in this sense means
going beyond just obeying law it means
sort of cultivating the various virtues
for the sake of making yourself better
by making your relations with other
people better
yeah relatively to be unjust towards
other people or to be to be vicious
towards other people isn't certainly to
be unjust towards them
so think about anger for example let's
let's not take you and your response
itself think about holding grudges we
can recognize that holding grudges is
not a good form of behavior right and
it's bad for beautiful grudges because
it affects you negatively and you know
makes you an angry sour person all the
time but it's also unjust in relation to
people who we should forget by the way
aerosol doesn't think if you give
everybody will talk about that a little
bit later he thinks there's something
you definitely shouldn't forget he's not
a term of a cute kind of guy but he does
think in a lot of cases having a
disposition of good humor in a good
temper sorry good temper means that you
actually do forgive people and you try
not to hold grudges that would be
hartley's contemplate Richard being
temperate could be about you making sure
that you don't eat too much don't drink
too much don't pursue the wrong kind of
pleasure so it doesn't mess up your own
body and make it tough for you to
deliver good life but it could also be
towards others like for instance I have
children so I want to try to live a long
time
my kids because that's part of being a
good parent for that so if I have to
take care of my body it's not just a
choice I'm making about my own
relationship with myself spouse we're
both out of shape gym together but it's
in relation to other people who count
you know there's other amazing you to
think about this too if I if I allow
myself to become morbidly obese and
diabetic I become weak I become a burden
on the rest of society because you know
in our society there's this expectation
that somebody else should pay for my
insulin and pay my treatments and all
that sort of stuff so that could be a
form of injustice you know now aerosol
them talks about fairness and here's
worry again he gets confusing he says
I'm going to talk about two kinds of
unfairness too many smuggle stuff here
this is what equals partial justice so
the two Kensie talks about will go into
these in a bit more detail for a couple
of minutes are what he calls justice in
distribution so let me call this
distributive justice sometimes it's
called commutative justice and the basic
idea behind this is when you have goods
that can be shared among people like
like money for example or specifically
in terms of money not just wealth but
income you know for getting jobs done or
political positions honors we can think
of a lot of other things we'll do some
brainstorming about that in a couple of
minutes these can be distributed fairly
or people can try and take more than
their fair share at the expense of
others doesn't that often happen when it
comes to say taking the credit for
things why don't you guys like doing
group assignments when you don't like
doing group assignments basically you're
shaking your head
because one person and the same all the
work and everyone else is like yeah
that's the worst case scenario right
sometimes even like you have like five
people in the group we had four people
do the work and then that one other
person's of the moocher of the free
rider yeah you have to depend to do
quality work
ah some people might just do the word
whenever the show face but it'll be
actually got all yeah and then you get a
bad grade in your life this is unfair
right because things are the grades are
good the grades are not being
distributed in accordance with what your
effort or your output with so many other
good yeah basically the same thing
sometimes if they do their work you end
up spending even more time editing
in which case you are making a greater
contribution than they are so you should
have a greater reward that that's a very
basic notion of that when we're dividing
up say food at the dinner table
should we give everybody exactly the
same portion or should some people give
you more the one really depends right if
they're all exactly having the same
bodily needs then it makes sense to give
everybody the same portion I hate going
to it that's like that because even if
you take like the extra pounds off of me
my ideal weight something about like 220
pounds because I have a big frame and
I'm a big guy and so if you're going to
get me the same little you know healthy
portion as you give some 110 pound woman
next to me I'm going to be hungry I
probably need you know two or three of
those in unity you know what that's like
you know if you're physically active you
actually need more food if you're
actually engaged in manual labor you
probably need more food than somebody
who's sitting at a desk all day yeah
it's just as a part of partial justice
ability center good question so partial
justice is a category that aerosol is
going to use distributive justice is one
type of partial justice let me put the
other one out there
this he calls directive and sometimes
it's called rectification
which is hard to say remember justice
when things have gotten out of whack
when the distribution is wrong when
people have taken more than their fair
share corrective justice sets things
right that is also a form of partial
justice and Aristotle says this can
happen a lot of different ways think
about criminal the way that that works
if we put somebody in prison we're not
just in capatch
not just keeping them out of the pool of
general population where they could hurt
other people we're imposing a penalty
we're taking something waving and
creating right lotto that it's doing
good food you know economic hardships
that come with it we're taking that away
because they already have too much of
something else the basic is here's where
you then says oh and by the way there's
also reciprocity and that's not the same
system it's not the same of this but
sometimes it looks like this so if you
got confused at that point you should
have gotten confused at that point you
were actually following along and you
know we threw something in that wasn't
supposed to be there it does fit
reciprocity is this very basic
concession when you do good for somebody
else they should do good for you when
you do harm or bad to somebody else they
should be able to do harm to you so what
we call poetic justice you know or with
a punishment fits the crime
you guys familiar with some of these uh
these judicial decisions where somebody
will have a a judge will impose a
punishment that's not a standard kind of
punishment because they want the
offender to actually you know see how
they're affecting other people some need
some parents do this with have you seen
these Facebook memes we're like there'll
be a kid who got drunk or something and
I'll be like them with a sign
say I'm being forced to post this on
page fo post this on Facebook because I
thought it was fun to go out and get
drunk and my mom's making me do this
that's what it was you know punishment
fits the crime
you guys seen these yeah somebody have
so reciprocity is a different kind of
fairness and you know when we get upset
with friends we say hey how come I do
these nice things for you and you don't
do them for me we're complaining about a
lack of reciprocity we're not
complaining about the fact that we only
you know a kitty that we're all pulling
out up and you're taking more than you
deserve or not you know corrective
things not being completely right we're
saying hey a basic level if I listen to
your BS when you vent about things you
can take the time to listen to mine the
attention is good that we give to each
other or you know I remember your
birthday why can't you remember my
birthday people are people get very
excited about that sort of thing
Facebook is also not helpful too because
you get probably a lot of friends feel
under pressure to like you know put
something on everybody wall okay I just
you know I did like with putting happy
birthday anyways well about a year and
my wife put something I like piggyback
on hers and say yeah for me too
that's peaceful you know Facebook is
that will light and we have to know we
have different sorts of friendship some
we're closer than others but I generally
don't don't do it anybody can part
because if I'm going to like do it for
some people then I feel like it for
everything right I don't feel like I got
like you know for under Facebook I know
someone you have a problem way more that
I don't feel like keeping up with 400
people's birthdays
I'm actually taking my own birthday off
so that nobody can wish me happy
birthday or make me feel guilty about
not wishing them a happy but that's all
reciprocity you see the difference
between the admin and these other four
there's one of the type that he talks
about it doesn't talk about it an awful
lot and the best way to translate it is
equity it's called FPA case maybe an
appropriateness would be another way to
translate it and that generally has to
do with legal justice and it tempers
legal justice so I don't know another
word that would actually especially for
CJ dangers this would this would fit in
exactly with one of the terms that comes
up which is discretion when you have the
capacity to opt to operate with
discretion that's what Aristotle is
calling equity what discretion is is
being able to do it
loosen up or not apply the full rigor of
the law or the rule or the procedure so
to take an example that we use for the
application assignments if the professor
doesn't you know apply the policy to the
student who's been found cheating and
it's that allows you to retake the test
that could be what we call equity or
or discretion there's a lot of cases
where we need to do this in part because
laws and rules and procedures are often
kind of blunt instruments so in some
cases it's more just to operate with
what Aristotle calls a flexible measure
so you notice justice means all these
different things so if you are getting
into an argument somebody it might be
because you have this in mind and they
have this in mind or if you have this in
mind and they have this invite you want
to be able to clarify what sense of
justice are you actually talking about
what sets of right and wrong of fairness
we Galilee are you actually putting on
the table where else you're going to run
into all these sorts of arguments and
even within this there there people can
get a target speaking like it's like
claim on identifying processes but he
loved these things in each other this at
the same time sometimes lesser there are
yeah there are going to be conflicts
where they will contradict each other
not all of them all all the same time
yeah to say equity in law by mass you
have equity precisely because the law on
this part is going to it's an instrument
of justice but it can become unjust
distributions could be made at one point
in time and then later on you realized
all that that looked fair at the time it
was really unfair so we need to correct
it we need to make reparations to
to change the matrix of opportunities or
things like that reciprocity and quite
often get into conflict refused to you
know in part because distributive
justice is often based on a like a
proportionality we're going to get into
that de minute whereas reciprocity is
more one-on-one so but that's that's the
sort of grand scheme what's going on in
that debt that book so you can see there
there's a lot of room for getting into
conflict about this